ethereum is that part of the blockchain
network
that can do any task you can ask for
like
it can perform transactions it can act
as a platform to develop and deploy
adapt
smart contracts can be created on it and
many more
every action on the ethereum network has
its own way and method of functioning
that is one of them which catches
people's eyes
every time for one or the other reason
so in today's video
we will focus on and explore about the
fairing dab
hey everyone i'm shanley and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on ethereum dapps in this video we will
explore
ethereum dash and will go through some
of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it first
we will understand what adapts or
decentralized applications
then we will explore what are smart
contracts
then we will look into the features of
that
then we will figure out why use ethereum
network for building the app
then we will explore the difference
between web applications
and decentralized applications
after which we will understand the
benefits of dapp
development
then we will have a look at the dab tool
then we will explore limitations of that
development
and at last we will explore top 5
ethereum dap projects
so without any further delay let's get
started with the video
so what are dacs or decentralized
applications
decentralized applications are
applications built on open source
peer-to-peer network of ethereum
blockchain technology
which uses smart contracts and front-end
users interface to create platforms
that are launched and streamlined
without intermediaries
and centralized authorities in terms of
user experience
it appears to be similar to other
available web applications
but they have a lot of differences
what are smart contracts a smart
contract is a form of code
that lives on the ethereum blockchain
that runs and functions
exactly as programmed quite similar to
normal contracts
once these contracts are deployed on the
network you can't alter them
which means you can't change or modify
them
that's a decentralized because they are
controlled only by the logic written in
the
into the contract and by not any
individual or company
which also means you need to design your
contracts very sensibly
and carefully
let's discuss some features of that
which makes them unique
and popular first is decentralized
this means dapps are independent and
cannot be controlled by any centralized
authority
second is turing complete dapps can
perform any task or action provided by
required resources
third is deterministic irrespective of
the environment
that performs the same function
everywhere
and the last one is isolated which means
they're executed in the ethereum virtual
machine
a virtual environment so that if there's
any kind of bug in the smart contract
it won't hamper the normal functioning
of the ethereum network
that makes me wonder why ethereum above
all blockchain network
is majorly used for creating data
there are several reasons why ethereum
is dominating the majority of that
development
first the ethereum is capable of
implementing a development
interface that can reduce programming
time as well as help in quickly
launching
projects second
the ethereum network consists of a
remarkably grown developer's community
since the platform plant
third ethereum greetings tremendous
network effects from its global
coalition of technologies which continue
to pursue the network and actively
develop users resources to encourage
adoption
and at last but not the least the
ability to monetize dapp projects
adequately stipulates the participation
of others in the ethereum network
but what makes dapps different from
other web applications
let's have a look at the difference
between web apps and that
in web application architecture there is
a front-end client and a back-end server
the content is majorly written using
html css and javascript
and the backend is written in django
node or rails for that the architecture
is the same
the front end is written in same
language as of web applications
but for backend blockchain technology
like ethereum
is used in web apps and apps they both
interact with
each other with json messages similar
to other applications
web app store user information at the
company headquarters
on a separate server usually however
that's consists of a data created by the
users
therefore the nodes are used to verify
the exchange when a user makes a
transaction on the dap
let's have a look at the benefits of
that
first is privacy that maintains the
privacy or anonymity of the user
which means you don't need to provide
your any kind of personal information
to deploy or interact with the data
second is complete data integrity
data stored on the ethereum blockchain
is immutable
due to cryptographic primitives no one
can forge
or manipulate transactions or other data
stored in the blockchain network
third is verifiable behavior smart
contracts can be analyzed and are bound
to execute in the directed ways
without the need to trust any central
authority
fourth is zero downtime once the app is
deployed on the blockchain the network
as a whole
will always be able to serve its client
looking to interact with the contract of
the dap
let's dive down and have a look at the
dab tools
rumble ui it's an adaptable component
and design standards for decentralized
application
one click dab it is a pause tool for
generating dark content
from an abi
and ether flow it is also a first tool
for ethereum developers to test their
node and compose and debug
rcc calls from the browser
so what now when we know everything
about that
let's understand the limitations of that
development
maintaining dabs can be a tough job
because code and data published on the
blockchain network
is very hard to modify
to achieve the high levels of security
integrity transparency and reliability
that ethereum aspires to every node of
its network needs to run
and store every transaction which leads
to huge performance overhead
the entire ethereum network gets backed
up if a single dapp is using too many
computational resources
sometimes it may be harder to engineer
and
configure user-friendly experiences
sometimes the average user might find it
too difficult to set up a tool stack
necessary to interact with the
blockchain in a truly secure manner
now let me take you through the five
best ethereum dapps projects
make a dao an italian-based protocol
that creates
the die stable coin and allows for
collateral backed loans
to be made without the use of a
middleman
uni swap a decentralized cryptocurrency
exchange
protocol chain link a blockchain oracle
network that is completely decentralized
axi infinity a blockchain b is trading
and battling game that
lets its players gather breed raise
battle and trade token-based entities
called axes
and thus ave an ethereum based
decentralized money market
that allows users to lend and borrow a
variety of crypto assets
this is all about ethereum dac we have
almost reached the end of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section
i hope you enjoyed this video on
ethereum dab and learn something new
from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button thanks for watching
this video
and stay tuned for more updates and
videos from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here